I can't believe it's already time to
talk about my favorite movies of 2015
this year has blown by and this was a
huge highly anticipated year filled with
tons of releases people were very
excited for myself included I salivated
at the thought of 2015 and now that the
year is here I'm excited to tell you
guys about my 10 favorite movies this
year because believe it or not there
weren't as many great movies as 2014
despite the fact that we were so excited
for 2015 because in 2014 my top list was
20 films and this year I only have 10 I
do have some honorable mentions though
but before I get into that list a few
things to keep in mind a grade a film
received does not matter here a great if
film receives is entirely for that film
maybe that film did everything perfectly
it doesn't mean that I necessarily liked
that film more than another film just
because I had a small flaw with that
other film so grades here don't matter
this is my chance one time every year to
just be like look these are the films
that I had the most fun watching in a
theater my first honorable mention is
the gift this movie surprised the hell
out of me Joel Edgerton starred in as
well as wrote and directed this film it
was one of Jason Bateman's best
performances Rebecca Hall was also
terrific in the movie and it had a
whopper of an ending that floored me
my next honorable mention is inside out
one of Pixar's best in years I love this
movie it brought me to tears it was a
beautiful animation with great human
emotion in fact the entire movie was
about emotion Steve Jobs a very
well-written very well acted movie that
I had a great time watching and Mission
Impossible rogue nation the fifth movie
in this franchise that continues to chug
along and bring us awesomeness alright
guys it has come down to it let's get
going with number 10
Sicario blew me away this movie was
realistically gritty and dark I felt
sick to my stomach when certain things
were shown in this movie and that was
the impact the movie should have had it
left a very dark impression on me Emily
Blunt was amazing in this movie in Roger
Deakins cinematography as usual gorgeous
spotlight is one of the best written
films of the year this movie riveted me
from scene 1 this movie was directed so
subtly and so held back that what rose
to the top was the need for justice for
victims and that is what should have
happened spotlight was terrific
the revenant is one of the best looking
films I've ever seen the cinematography
in this movie blew me away
Leo DiCaprio is again fantastic this guy
continues to impress me his performance
here was very physical minimal dialogue
in fact even some of the dialogue he did
have was in another language he had one
of the most intense scenes of the year
involving a bear
terrific acting and brutal realistic
violence that just exploded off the
screen Ridley Scott's the Martian was
such a return to form I was so excited
to see Ridley Scott back directing an
excellent movie and Matt Damon's turn as
this astronaut who stranded on Mars was
brilliant because it's averted
expectations and a movie like this you
expected to be really depressing and sad
and had this guy be alone and crying all
the time but he found the humor in the
situations and made the movie so much
fun it was so light-hearted which was
such a different thing to see with a
film like this also the special effects
were great it's Ridley Scott's best
movie in years and it's one of Matt
Damon's best performances of all time
when Marnie was there is quite possibly
Studio Ghibli's final film at least for
now that's the way it's looking not
enough people saw this movie I'm sure a
lot of you don't even know what this
movie is Studio Ghibli if you don't know
has made some of the best animation of
all time and when Marnie was there was a
gorgeously beautiful haunting animated
film about friendship about being
socially introverted about discovering
your family roots about discovering who
you are as a person and it floored me
and I'm talking floored me the ending of
this movie had my eyes welling up with
tears it affected me in such a personal
way it's a beautifully beautifully
hand-drawn animated film and if it is
Studio Ghibli 's last they went out with
a bang
Spielberg you still got it my friend
bridge of spies is my favorite Spielberg
film since Munich I think it's his best
film in at least a decade he did
terrific work on this movie and Tom
Hanks as the everyman who we all know
him to be just shines in this role and
that's something he does so well you can
watch a Spielberg movie and not even
imagine the amount of ingenuity that
goes into every frame that this guy is
creating the movie was fun it was
dramatic it was powerful it was well
acted and it said something very
important that two opposing nations who
have two different views can get along
Quentin Tarantino in my mind did it
again with the hateful eight some people
didn't love this movie as much as his
other films but I found a great amount
of enjoyment watching a bunch of angry
people snowed in at a lodge trying to
figure out which one is the culprit I
loved the location of this movie I loved
the feel of this movie I loved the
dialogue of this movie samuel l jackson
and his monologue about you know what
you guys know that scene rocked it was
awesome
I loved this entire film Kurt Russell
dragging Jennifer Jason Leigh around and
she also giving a fantastic performance
my gosh for me the hateful eight was
like watching a movie that was released
in the 1960s except with all the
restrictions lifted out of it that would
have been on a film released at that
time I'm a fan of the rocky franchise
but I'm not a humongous fan of the rocky
franchise I really only loved one or two
of them Creed might actually be my
favorite of the entire franchise and
that's saying a lot because this is the
seventh movie this movie affected me
emotionally right here so deep it just
dug into me Sylvester Stallone gave the
best performance honestly maybe of his
entire career and Michael B Jordan was
utterly terrific in this movie it had a
great musical score Ryan Coogler came in
with his script and direction and just
reinvigorated this franchise now these
last two I really really really really
really really struggled over I rewatched
both of them multiple times before doing
this list I mean a lot I really
struggled over this and I thought a lot
about this and I really really thought
about it and then I thought about it
some more you guys get the point I
really wanted to make sure that I put
these on the right place for me I
already reviewed both of these movies
and you guys know what I think of these
movies but I wanted to make sure that
for me these movies were in the place
that were honest to myself and that's
why my pick for number two is
Mad Max fury road is one of the best
action movies ever made it was filled
with practical effects amazing stunt
work mind-blowing set pieces and one of
my favorite characters of the entire
year that of furiosa played by Charlize
Theron this is the only movie this year
that I gave an A+ to because I feel that
this movie did everything that it should
have done as flawlessly as it could have
and this movie is also one of the very
few movies that has come out recently
where I genuinely had a sense of
discovery while watching it a sense of
how the hell did they do that that is so
rare nowadays because of the advent of
CGI we go to movies and we just expect
some guys sat in a room and probably did
it on a computer and worked on it for
many hours but when I watched this movie
there was genuinely a sense of
wonderment of how this film was made and
it was awesome so guys you can probably
already tell my pick for number one is
this was the movie that for me
personally I had the most fun watching
in a theater this year I have to be
honest if I said that I didn't have more
fun watching this movie than any other
movie that was released this year I
would be lying to you I would be
dishonest to you and I can't do that and
that is why my favorite movie of 2015 is
Star Wars The Force awakens did
everything for me that I wanted it to do
is it very similar to a new hope in
regards to plot structure and certain
things that occur absolutely in reality
pretty much every Star Wars movie is
very similar to the other Star Wars
movies there's seven of them now and
there's really only so much you can do I
also look at the fact that Abrams had to
relaunch a franchise and the past three
films people were mostly disappointed in
I know fans of the prequels are out
there that's fine if you like the
prequels cool I've never once said that
I hate the prequels I just think they're
really disappointing my point is that
the force awakens did everything that
this movie should have done it tributed
the old paying homage to the old well
giving it a whole new fresh sense with
characters like Rey and Finn and Poe and
the brilliantly realized kylo Ren who is
not a perfect complete evildoer
he's a person behind that mask he has
problems he's conflicted when he takes
that mask off and he's just a person
like some guy a lot of people said I was
disappointed I was expecting Darth Vader
kylo in this movie is a person he's not
done training yet that made him so much
more interesting you understood why he
was doing the things that he was he was
pained
such a great villain Rey was freaking
great Daisy Ridley was a revelation as
that character if I told you that this
wasn't the most fun I had watching a
movie this entire year and that I didn't
like it more the next two times that I
saw it
well I'd be lying and I'm gonna go a lot
more in depth about this when the
blu-ray is released I'm gonna bring back
my analyze reviews segment you guys have
been begging me to do more of those they
take forever to make but I am gonna do
one for the force awakens when that
blu-ray footage is available guys 2015
wow thank you so much seriously really
truly honestly from the bottom of my
heart for sticking with me for another
year for having fun with me talking
about movies because that's what this is
all about this is about film and fun and
just discussing movies with other people
who love to talk about movies who feel
passionate about film and that's me and
I found so much of that in you guys and
that's so great I
of doing this thank you once again stay
tuned for my picks for the worst films
of 2015 in just a couple days I can't
wait to bring that list to you guys
because that's that's gonna be fun oh
boy
guys you're the best and as always thank
you so much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck my nice